i ragazzi ragazzuoli funziona dove solo
vedere se funziona live
mamma mia mamma mia mamma mia che
giocata rega che giocata incredibile
abbiamo finito getting over it in live
perché si fosse connesso adesso che si
trova non elencato il mio canale poi
uscirà pubblico incredibile ha messo
un'ora e mezza
not bad non siamo con il buon thomas
chatham ei la mano a me manca un tipo 55
mila per raggiungere madonna incredibile
che busti di iscritti grazie mille
ragazzi dove si fanno stasera la che no
ma una roba allucinante non so cosa
succederà vamo a mancavano 15 mila ne
mancano 5 mi ha fatto 10 mila iscritti
in bonora e allora il momento giusto
sarà modalità che sono partecipi a 5
milioni in live non lo so oggi svegliamo
domani o non lo so
grazie ragazzi davvero apprezzo
tantissimo ho voluto magna sarei
aspettato di partecipare a questo grande
ma manco io in realtà in live
anzi speriamo che non succede mai
perduta perché non so come reagirà
questa maglia perché non so come reagirà
il mio figlio si lava augurando di non
vedervi raga ai na'vi voglio non li
voglio no non è vero però minchiate sono
proprio logo sono preso troppo bene dai
rocchetti amo per chi ha voglia o
spezzato la live in due addirittura
saldato quella di prima con un pezzo è
questo il nodo che ancora più ordinato
dai sei dentro quasi sono dentro adesso
vai
il gruppo degli dei tom nostra speck e
scusami i primi di ricordarmi toglie
mistero ma anche personalizzo l'auto c'è
qualcosa di tamarro
[Musica]
ciao margherita c'è adriana chaton solo
gentilissimi invito ai giocatori al tv
no veramente ragazzi grazie veramente
per tutto il supporto gentilissimi non
mi aspettavo assolutamente né di finire
che ti ngo veri ma non ebbero a tassi me
lo aspettavo perché l'ultima volta mi
ero abbastanza skillato quindi sapevo
più o meno come finirlo se la sborone
già però alla fine sarà alla fine sia
arrivata al 20 per cento finale di male
ma mi sento fortissimo rispetto mezz'ora
fiero cioè messo un'ora e venti però
andavano nei 29 10 10 minuti con tre
reti di altro un'ora però fa era tutto
il 20 per cento finale del gioco perché
la prima parte ho fatto i venti minuti e
il restante che ci ho messo c'è un messi
tipo 50 il prezzo del secchio non
riuscivo
vabbè se ci sei giochiamo capitali e si
vola si vuole magari da un po che non
tocco dove si stanno già parlando il
culo
il joystick per rock clean
dài e dài entrato la negatività
ufficiale proprio lui proprio non è
arrivata l'era trovai c'è un bacione
sull'antenna che è successo
grazie mille serafica saville emanuele
questo il dirty qui entra in loop
l'audio quando ci sono le donazioni che
vedo però boh ha però non dover perché
qua si sente dalle casse capitolo senti
anche tu mi sa a partito mi sentii male
adesso mi percy sentire bene grande
soffre di pad e non succede spesso mi
sono ricordato che ai microfoni delle
cuffie
allora ragazzi siamo nel club degli dei
come sapete il capo degli dei non perde
mai e oggi non perdono statua tutta mia
vai come si ci parli della champions
league juve sta qui non pensare male
sono carico grazie mille rider penombra
necrologio rischio il mio amico senza la
stessa livesey lo farò sicuramente
adesso mi ha detto che c'è non sapevo
avessero fatto nuovo penombra però mi
pare che hai detto nascosto lei perché
non è un cenone è una moda del giusto
però secondo me può regalarci
soddisfazioni da farò sicuramente un
auto adesso mi impegno mi hanno parlato
anche di un nuovo super meat boy la
bussola e di quello a quello me l'hanno
detto non ha idea di quanta gente mela
l'incauto in settimana non ho idea tutti
praticamente a cosa ho sbagliato la
palla è buona norma che si così avanti a
me ne hanno parlato a puntati però nel
2019 quindi non possiamo farlo adesso
ma sì adesso invece quando esattamente
ad aprile ad aprile e allora ciao mia
banca non sotto 100 mesi ma che sarà il
primo gol della serata
si chiama maria quello che pensa super
meat boy dai primo deve essere nostro
perché siamo noi quelli rosa o leggo ha
riconosciuto le nostre vere non avevo
dubbi
il mio progetto porca vacca non ha
segnato la città sono di me li merita di
avere detto che recupero magnificat a me
li trasferisce così di mm di passo
boom o questa è bella questa è bella
ecco arriva lui proprio lui
dalla metà campo dal muro dice no ma chi
è florenzi barcellona esce bene florenzi
ter stegen porta 1 a 0 per il club
d'elite a 0 disabili day si distingue
non solo per il rosa aia e grande fiorni
di hun 6 però vabbè ormai vacca è opera
difficile era difficile perché lavorato
bene comunque non vorrei dire ma noi
siamo già rancati quindi io sono platino
due lisci starete nostra gente non
proprio
bronzo per me almeno per per cook si
resta gente strong vi prego raga non mi
chiedete di salutarvi né donazioni
bruttissimo cioè almeno schifati nella
domanda proprio così comunque ti saluto
ciao però che prima però non voglio sia
un esempio sbagliato ogni volta volevo
dire in un live ecco che siamo state la
chiesa ancora tu che sei un
uno strip tra chiedo dopo questa cosa va
e siri piazza arriva non è vero no
perché non c'ho creduto bravo com
non ci avevo creduto perché pensavo
andasse fuori guarda qua non ci ho
creduto però la prendesse invece una
presente ottenuta li ha messo il turbo
arcobaleno ecco perché siamo rosa il
bravo ti dicevo tu che sei streamer chi
fa donazioni per essere salutato e basta
tu come la vedi come cosa c'è nei sensi
non lo faccio mai se chiedo di non farmi
donazioni possono notare perché mi
sembra una roba brutta cioè che uno
d'ogni tipo 5 euro dimmi ciao salute e
di così il saluto nell'invito fa la
domanda lo fai comunque quindi si va
bene quindi viene comunque ringraziato
quello è un gioco da ragazzi giovani che
non ti lascia giocare
non so di me quindi il senatore che io
debba mi fa troppo impazzire solo di
quello te lo dirò sempre
e si è implicito saluto quindi raga io
metterei una domanda si domanda almeno
assenso no c'è invece che saluti
salutami e basta che brutto che darà
sono proprio contento non finito 29
riguardo ma io non vorrei dire ma è la
missione numero 2 arrivare a 5 milioni
stasera e allora finire che ci cova
stiamo vincendo contro dei platino 29 35
milioni attimo
guardalo note la posta si era buonissima
invece hai fatto una gran cosa
sono stato in campo avrei dovuto
sfruttare la meglio e mi stai sassola
imparando massima cosa ha fatto corsi
serali di recupero diroccati scusami
vanno messi punti intermedi adesso
ma vedo che ci sono i palati non sono
più a multipli di 5 punti rockets league
sono 132 306 hanno aggiunto punti
intermedi non paga voi avete capito in
che lingua sta parlando è bene farlo
normale sventa poi dice che parlò prima
solo che sa che quando facevi i punti ti
dava tipo o multipli tutti i multipli di
cinque quindi non potevano ai 138 cioè
oltre 130 135 x paese adesso sarà capito
non sono più tipi di 5
possiamo ancora ancorate resistere per
un minuto 22 ce la possiamo fare
siamo con un colore un po strano lo so
nella squadra di conte ma non lo so
ragazzi siamo siamo così siamo il club
degli dei capelli dei va bene anche a
rosa se quella domenica cosa contro rosa
qualcosa contro il club degli dei
ci saremo noi allora vediamo non perdere
visto che siamo a 3 a 2 per cortesia
aprirà la sezione più solo che cosa ha
sbagliato e non sono di nuovo in porta
un grande errore spazio oggi la toglierà
di mezzo
eccola un minuto dobbiamo resistere tom
io credo in noi sei più difensivo 6
piuttosto più difensivo bravo vedrà un
peccato peccato madonna allora età per
l'ultimo aspettavo
aiuti a 47.000 stiamo sudando come delle
lepri ci provano edizione nata aspetta
dunque io deve stare sempre in porta
tipo
mamma mia che bella palla è tolto bravo
togli la propria butta là su io non ho
tutti escono che riparte la rassegna
segna segna
ti prego bene vero secondi dolore parola
ti prego si no
vado dalla segna lui girati nella
bottega di cadice la bandierina cercando
uno contro uno dentro del piero del
piero alex andiamo a berlino andiamo a
prenderci sti 5 milioni i capelli del
non perde neanche sui 5 milioni non
perde mai non perde mai let's go
ammirare un baleno ma mi sa che mi si
sta pagando il counter degli iscritti
non vedo che si aggiornava prima ogni
secondo adesso rimane freezzato per un
po perché sta facendo tipo controlli che
sta succedendo
chi vuole mettere ansia allora stai
giura chi lo paga il counter non lo vedo
a giornata ea chi guarda e ti dico lo
guardo io sei 95 95 95 manca in cina
vedi 5 mia casa ci manca ma mi ha
regalato a prescindere da come va al
truck all incredibile
tanta roba spero non finito già
arrivarci stai per garantirgli però
domani ci svegliamo servola interrotti
dai la prima piano vinta sua compagna
male possiamo notare anche tu a 64 al
team
si vola su skype lei ha subito sberle ne
aspetta
ma se non pensavo fossi importano la
vittoria messa malissimo per fare gol io
l'ansia palla che rimane quello ed ios
si chiama la mano
l'abbiamo già affrontato la scorsa volta
me lo ricordo da un'altra nostra l'altro
mi sembra dice che guardano come vola
bene quella che presentano turbo mentre
fatto che non ci credo che avevo fatto
fermi tutti ma ha messo benissimo ho
volato sito orto come la morte guarda il
pallone il drago guardatelo incredibile
la mette lì io l'ho tipo icardi
grazie a tutti per il pollo intanto in
ciad io mi lancio sul pallone parte 2
c'è anche l'ora bravo il cio ed angola
la bandierina ma ma fregato dai e se ne
di ios
oltre alle hai qualcosa delle nazioni
devo aggiornare la pagina per leggerle
scusatemi ragazzi devo aspettare che
finiamo sta partita non risco a leggere
più niente se no perché mi si è badato
alla lista delle donazioni non vedo
nulla di quello che mi è arrivato sorry
adesso finisca partite dalle ore al
giorno che si è buona buona cavolo fosse
stata più forte era buono invece è però
una volturno attenzione occhio perché 3
anch'io spazzano proprio loro
sempre 1 0 3 minuti 50 sul cronometro
palla ha lanciato amanti degli avversari
non è la situazione sottesa di jos la
mano de dios ios santos la toglie
abbiamo tolta con una doppia deviazione
importante sarà arrivo dietro arrivo
dietro spa vj e mezzo bravo nole cerca
d'aiuto ricorreremo ricorrere
velocissimo ci sono importa sono in
parte eccola cercherò loro attenzione
potrebbero ripartire le parti di parti
uomo riparti di parti di parti non
riparte non riparte non la tocca non fa
niente
va beh
o magari vi sta dietro a prendere per i
fondelli ma non lo so se sei questi
commento mette ansia
ecco la città si cala sempre bravo uomo
vai vai tutto su tutti su tutti i siti
12 di turbo ma che ci sono da letto e
mezzo dai referendum e si no eh si
proprio vicino aspetta gol a un secondo
dalla fine
gg bello bello bello bello arrivare che
ha scusate vive le nazioni con l'elenco
che era molto fuori dallo specchio da
parte molto bene vai vai spingi è quindi
fingi credici
ora se non solo mai sono messo male ho
mai saltato arrivo perché fatto questa
cosa mi ha dato il tiro in porta viero
zitto perché ero concentrato riuscire a
fare questa cosa
porca vacca vieni qua aspettava doveva
in mezzo ai mezzo sono in mezzo quanti 4
di tumore molto bene pirlo bene molto
bene ed io se la toglie
no l'ho mancato rischiato e infatti mi
sa caratteristiche bravo tu forse la
toglievo anch'io non lo so però bravo
viene tolto vogliono ridata attenzione
però ci bravo salta balla e mezzo ancora
lui
la riprova salto anche secondo uomo tale
mezzo proprio buttato in mezzo non così
magari proprio che aveva prima fa niente
non fa niente va bene o se questo un
tiro bellissimo aia no sono entrato
nella porta perché per toglierla mi ero
impegnato tantissimo perché lo storto
che sfiga insegnato sul finale guardali
che sfiga se fosse un po più avanti
vabbè dai 1 a 1 meritati meritati deve
recuperare fermare di maria carmela li
noto va bene niente
molto buono questo
no ma meno estroso travagliato mi ha
fregato
occhio a mettere la palla in angolo
bene ruolo buono ci riprova provate
tieni latynina tiene a va bene lo stesso
trova la rete che prova a tirare l'acqua
sono va in mezzo tira lavoro studiosi si
gioca per 44 secondi alla fine teniamo
la vediamo la bassa ma amiamo devo fare
una roba per non fermarlo in mezzo sono
un casino
che cosa è successo mi è rimasta
legatissima nel gioco da qualche modo si
salva butta la butta la butta la propria
punta dentro talento si sono mai tirate
arcavacata sopra lo zero di turbo mi
attira molto non ci credo ma tolto lui
ma tolto lui guarda che pirla guarda che
pirla mi ha tolto lui la sto prendendo
ma tolto molto luminosa ma io chiedo al
bar
secondo me ce la fai a ballo ma ha tolto
ma spesso stato ci voglia non pensato in
potesse spingere le finali che ci credo
era lei che ci credo ma per lesioni
controlla c6 chiede a casa della
fraterna prova a crederci troppo forte
scusami l'arcobaleno non basta ok molto
buono
ripartono loro 10 secondi alla fine
insegnerà adesso no togli lato tagliati
pregara tal modo che kakà che achara che
non riesco all'intervista adesso dopo vi
leggo giuro scusate con l'a22 e la
l'ansia ragazzi la sentite l'ansia 2 a 2
e chi fa gol vince l'emozione signore
aia trova toccare devo avere il tour
basta che non ripartono ecco come onde
ecco una cosa non devo far fare e per
tensione però un al turbo dios
buono buono buono briano modo che è
rimbalzata male toglierla bravo bravo
provati dall'immenso tirale mezzo tirato
in mezzo proprio e proprio con un angolo
eccola non è vero cosa porto salutato
stortoni ai riparti parti per chi parte
ti prego toglie da lì madonna toglie a
togliere a toglierla parlano di dio
bravissimo la sala uno sbagliato lì
basta rapì saltarsi da gol
questo potrebbe far male
dio se la prende no no la mano de dios
l'abete per il 3 a 2 ci ha fregati a
tutti e due
gigi dai se lo sono meritati cg non era
melandri scusatemi ragazze non l'ho
letto della nazione adesso però dovevo
cioè non mi sarà pagato il cosa adesso
vi leggo tutti sonori lega la mano de
dios mano degli on
adesso vi leggo scusatemi difetto mi si
paga il coso che vendono su youtube non
leggo più niente dove viaggiano alla
pagina
secondo londra mette la divisione allora
grazie mille a tutti quanti siete
grazia le chiedo grazie fab ai cicloni
voglio nullo la stadio si parli la
storia la maglia ragazza sara viozzi
mille grazie agli chef grazie già col us
si è scoperto che anno fa che il
ragazzino ora se compri scritti come ci
si sente e ragazzini pro grazie grazie
di carinaro e basta è vero ciao mickey
grazie mille grazie bea grazie dario
scusatemi l'attimo se se veramente si
bak ha proprio tutto perché a volte vedi
messaggi sfasati li vedo che arrivano
dopo e devo riavviarla live sfide c'è
riavviare riaggiornata partendo dalla
nostra perché il nostro problema
ciao amici un bacino quindi corride
andiamo su andiamo a farne un'altra
light 11 normale dai c'è una ragione
tranquilli però almeno l'abbiamo giocata
non l'abbia giocata male era giocata
molto bene anche loro era gigi avremmo
dovuto raccontare meglio in lesioni ma
non ben note band dai e 30 ancora minuti
di live in 30 minuti di live e devo
qualcosa farei dire di vincere
faccio il plasma e diviene vinciamo e le
scrive atlante gli dèi tutto come sempre
che la demo day contro il gas si parla
sempre lì casa la propria vi piace porta
bene raga lo sento come vola bene non
neve ma allora ci vogliono tutti male
c'è di secondo me i miei melai volta
quindi secondo me è ok
raga io passione poi ovviamente in mezzo
alle 20 in mezzo eccola controllo ayachi
arrivato quello storto ma spinto proprio
bravo kira kira bravo quindi si gioca
bene giocata di m 34 difensiva ci devi
mai cry 3 è uno dei miei giochi
preferiti in assoluto da play 2 dm chino
vorrei che facessero un remaster
tantissimo e figli era bellissimo
bellissimo strutture modalità quando lo
finivi che erano tante ma dainese
finissimo veramente più
ahia ahia varco schifo per niente è
perché mi sono distratta guarda le
donazioni o mi deve distrarre lega devo
leggerlo e solo alla fine solo alla fine
devo leggere perché sono ministri non
leggo più premier ha anche paura che
perdo raga è un pochino allora quando le
foto tranquilli visto che capello
automatico ma che battuti arriva niente
poi andiamo superbo cementi dico la
stessa cosa
agliano nor anche per viaggi eccolo
quale come la ferma
che giocatore è siamo andati male per
niente però a colori riparare note raga
notte chi è sto andando note note note
note a tutti ciak si gira da ligi al 13
non ho erano tutto pd la controlla
preferisce ma non a turbo per andare in
cielo
no ho fatto una normale veramente ovvero
briosa speriamo che la live non l'abbia
salvato occhio e la mente mamma mia che
kakà è pazzo lo fa lui gioca per gli
altri è sceso non sa cosa chiede cosa
farà quello che sarà una materia nella
spazio l'altro è arrivato palesemente
bene ma lontana pugni dopo niente fa
tutto fa gol file e per gli altri fa gol
per i discutine a loro fa tutto lui va e
basta che poi altri due gol dalla nostra
parte ci diamo aspetta che gli ho
lasciato un po strano
sì lo re magi rivale dove si presa
meglio e ci arriva lui nella foto
riusciamo a fare una roba decente ma
come te l'ho tolta ma perché non c'erano
pure culo già incredibile da vedere ma
come te l'ho tolto guardate la torta
perfetta proprio dai questa recuperare
ciò che invece la facciamo impossibile
che la basi anche se va bene
in tre minuti che sarà vinciamo rai la
tempestiva ferma la questo rimane quanto
bene sono pronta alla che va però si
trova a long time e la fresa ma figurati
c'ero io era gol tre volte questo c'è
peccato occhio ai suoi balla molto bene
lo scusami scusami non sono stato
invitato perché mi avete la palla
fortissimo vento preso vai vai ma ci va
ci spiega dante bravo adelante segno art
1 a 3 per poi avere questo deve metterla
bene privato infatti la cicca perfetto o
toglie come riesco mi chiamasse la
francia arriva lario fra male proprio
male
buono due minuti abbiamo tutto il tempo
tra le due facce di dirgli e facciamo e
facciamo sono in mezzo dai no era bella
farà belle
per ora tocca infatti la trucca un
minuto e 42 sul cronometro a quello
riparte da non ce la fa non ce la facevo
io
togli la bravo può prende litiganti il
terzo gode
ma la palla rimane di molto bene vai vai
vai su hamas e qua ho un po ma tema ma
ora che quello che ci hanno questi ma
che culo al contrario era quello
ma dai ma che se cioè noi ci sempre
imprese i pali gol questi quei gol che
devono prezzi non si centrava questa mi
offendeva post facciamo con la adesso è
tutto più facile
sì ma rimarrà non sta entrando niente
incredibile anche come contro anche juve
inter
vabbè aia ecco l'ho detto quando non
gira la partita non c'è verso gli
abbandoni a bari non è impossibile
quando vediamo mira non lo gira capo non
c'è verso
gigi gigi next time quest'andata martini
devo la felpa che mi concentro di più
gigi gigi ste marco riporterà i forti
knight forse solo proviamo insieme che i
marmi segnalo caro thomas mi insegna a
giocare o qualcun altro che sa giocare
mi sembra che hai detto babzine grande
oggi a cagà ho detto proprio pub g che
coincidenza
grazie alla stagione 3 grazie lì oggi
questa partita la dovete cancellare dai
ricordi faceva schifo sbagliato tutto
non entrava niente all'altra parte
entravano tutti quello cha spalletti
come avatar o sbaglio
è stata una scomparsa e spalletti però
a spalletti per me lui luciano le sexy
luciano cosa stava facendo uno per un
secondo e sei solo se sono arrivati me
ma non ero storia
l'arena è piccola potrebbe dare luogo a
un sacco di gol
ecco che riparte nostro supereroe si
porta la palla sulla fascia e da fare
molto bene allora davvero mai rs non mi
parlano tutte le palle che tiro verità
si baciano e che gli arcobaleni però
secondo ma ciò è lo so ma di la verità
ti piacerebbe guardalo lì riparte
proprio lui a parte la fan fiction sono
in mezzo con zero di turbo mingiardi
successo arrivò secondo lega eccolo lì
che da circa la butta su proprio lui
nell'angolino spezia
non volevo controllarla seguono aspetta
forse non la prende ma dai non entra
proprio nulla o macchiato turchia la
tensione lo lasciate l'altro grazie ai a
questo video lo zero o meno domanda è
andata bene grazie al cie luz
forse gli averi presa comunque che se
fosse entrato lo so vai a arrivo arrivo
riferivo ciao non è la stessa palla c'è
la spinosissima è invece la busta no non
è cosa da noi che strano la prima volta
che succede oggi non dovevi dirlo questa
è la condanna ma tira la tira porca
vacca vai la casta nota ppg figisc butta
dentro
bravo eccola ballo live view iscritto
anche vanno creato un nuovo account per
te questo e altro grazie alla targa
se tutti fossero come te ne saremo a 15
milioni di iscritti iscrivete con tutti
account che avete mannaia un bacio
recchia grazie mille
docenti ragazzi riccardo siete stati
super oggi tutti gli account
la famiglia e iscrivetevi anche il nonno
grazie mille ragazza però oggi
apprezzato tantissimo quello che avete
fatto e allora vi dedico questa parata
che mi hanno fatto bella dedico tutto il
mio gol ma che dedica il gol
la parata vera quella che mi ha
mescolato check out lo hai pendere
dovrei di partire la mi hanno fregato il
turbo proprio questi qua quindi non
l'hanno proprio mi dovresti butta
lavorare 10 o sarà rotto ma ce la faremo
ci sono insomma lontana se non ci sono
pronto io allontana pugnitopo da butta
su eccola in due amici che fra un po di
trambusto in area mamma mia questa è
bella
però c'è sempre qualcuno sono in realtà
sono in dodici non livelli gli altri
dieci
tutto ok sono fatta di vincerlo andava
molto bene
eccomi per un istante lo facevo
pallonetto signore molto bene allora
ecco qua devo carica dare in piedi non
se ne italiano che rispetta evocate
riempie di k palla e mezzo tutta la
busta punta motoria via via via via via
via meno male vada fatto abbassare
ovviamente vi prenderò il turbo
maledetto 80 secondi alla fine lo re può
fare gol non segna ma neanche per
sbaglio c'è sempre qualcuno segnano loro
1 a 1 e la perderemo chi governa tutto
alla parata tom grigg cosa sta
insinuando la stessa eccola carla niente
la palla gol incredibile entrata dopo 20
tiri assuma possibile ma da un
incredibile oggi è assurdo non
interpreti la soccer ha sempre fatto
farlo ti guarda e aspettare toccato
anche tu a me l'ha dato nella nota si
veda la vendita sabrina ciao ragazzi vai
do min groppali bravo palla che rimane
lì molto bene luca bella aprendo invece
si è la riprendo io la riprende lui è
questo il forfait di gigi chi gira così
grazie riccardo per oggi davvero studio
le loro è morto ragazzi come ouloto vi
sentite
ora sì che è successo non sono
preoccupato che succede
ma dopo te non mi sentivo tipo 5 secondi
ok al gol
in pratica è rotto il microfono e vissi
so che oggi occhio oggi vi avrei 40
secondi possono vorrei che possono
recuperare benissimo affidati l'odio
verso il temuto ma la visuale sicardo
molto gentile ma dove sul pallone
vai
pensione lor domanda su io sono in mezzo
solo lui
mamma mia non era perfetto nello ciao
chiuderla lì potrei mezzo e sono loro ok
20 secondi alla fine nostri avversari ci
vogliano provare cosa vuol fare quello
lezione la garra charrúa eccolo non
invada la vedi
per la seconda evitare del giorno eccoli
tale mezzo dai buono buono buono degli
dei ma vincere ancora una volta tutto
l'arcobaleno per te
raga siamo super powers non voglio
andare 2006 di 5 milioni baracca non so
se ci arriviamo stasera mancano 5 mila
iscritti ancora so nota sono pochi
rispetto a quanto resa modalità live ma
sono ancora tanti quindi tranqui ci
arrivano comunque domani e se ci
arriviamo dopo domani quindi tranquilli
siamo lì quindi la reazione dello
speciale lo avrete sabato promesso
promesso tutti non dovete perdere perché
la cosa più incredibile del mondo nel
nome lo sa già vano di lo posso dire
agli altri
no non è vero che sono dentro quindi
tranquilli e come promesso video con sun
mercoledì e con ice si volta e con esino
6 via vai
vado a prendere la turbo in difesa
allegria nelle tavole mi su questi
ragazzo bravo
no ero ciccata pensa che la sbaglia
troppo bravo bravo sbaglia due volte
gigi tavole miss miss anno di nomi un po
orientaleggianti è questi è quindi sono
stati vani jan mayen jean sono fuori non
ce la faremo mai a batterli
va subito a prendere il turbo ancora una
volta la prima palla volante town si
erge in volo e non la tocca meno male
che visse fissare convincente arbitro
spetta il controllo lo controlla lui è
un problema
non so come impararla un'allegra ciccata
grande l'ora grandissimo arrivo se solo
se solo se sono valsi così 20 la
controllano loro la partita guarda come
se lei bevuto come un altro io il mio
avatar non avevo visto
ricordatevelo cambiati la prima volta
che metto la mia faccia su steam e vado
l'artiglio che cosa stavo facendo il mio
vedere verso gli youtuber lo capisci
l'artiglio che graffia la guarda lo re
mi cambiò il nome così adesso e perfetti
fatto stava andando indietro non vedevo
niente vola due gol così si vola se oggi
siamo credibili lacerato dai chiudiamo
col 40 mettiamo la parola ora tocca al
volo la cic e allora da solo davanti al
portiere che non c'è non sbaglia
l'appoggio 40 gg
no non è vero nei gg pero spero forfeit
perfetta know forfait in forfettino
forfait di pianoforte forfettino
profittare se vado a non andare io
carpet dei cc 6 penso che devo andare
sulla palla e mi metti un attimo per
attimo di ansia
eccolo lo ha ri ma come minimo che ho
detto cdp in tutti i quattro gol e fanno
quinto socio
spaziamo perdendo cosa stai facendo
laveno nel momento signorelli palla
questo è cattivo è successo mammamia
stava per entrare non si era successa
una cosa il gol dell'anno ma tocca via
qualche modo mazza che tiro che ha fatto
questo macchia ma chi arriverà più lui
non ne sbagliano non è vero mirata ed
ero peso al palo che vale l'ora e
ripiglia la pila riprende volta non so
come ho sfruttato tutto il turbo che
avevo tutti i saldi le propulsioni tutto
solo si vendica lui attenzione per palla
che va là ci sai riprendeva che la mamma
mia musica che lancia fatto per la
stiamo lottando veramente pesantemente
sarà coi denti
questo è bello però non importa ora sì
che porta provate a togliere in tutti i
modi a dai quattro ordini di un cazzo
perché potrebbero recuperare in un tra
un secondo e l'altro ve lo dico perché
mi è successo non sai quante volte da 0
a 5 anni fa vincere che l'avete persa
sul 4 a 0 ma il successo lei e
conoscendo le mie live potrebbe
succedere sono solo il realista non mi
stupirei ti giuro non mi stupirei per
niente però la mette in mezzo la
chiudono lo stesso e non ci sei vabbè
all'acquis ma io non ho capito ma i
colori delle squadre randomico quando
fai quando vai tipo in club si toccava
allora dài qui dopo lo stop atto stupido
e che il modo visto qui dover far gol al
posto del più caro di intentato il tipo
più mi ha lanciato in avanti grazie a
guardare un tocco due docce
gigi avrà 5 1 si fa
no era fuori fuori fuori il cuore non
c'è nessuno sega ha meno male che data
storica
eccolo barone ma proprio la presa avevo
prossimo sento di rimpalli limite entro
la parata pazzesca ma come ha fatto a
prenderla ti giuro incredibili ma luce
qualunque imparato a poter poteva fare
la mettevo del problema non so come sia
pazzi dai 52 the picture of the
monnalisa isa wars è solo che avvisa che
sono davvero orientali di terzi e amici
mao tse tung larry potere 4 0 che porta
una sfiga incredibile fede per lost
mannaggia mamma mia mi odi e mezzo per
town che la piazza della uliana ho fatto
un tiro incredibile tra l'atro come
facciamo noi abbiamo fatto prima vincere
4 0
e tu devi vivere il momento non devi
farti domande se ne buona l'ora la lunga
la faccia ciò che lui
ma porca di quella barca arrivo
occhio
o
mentre debutta la butta dentro
avvenne in porta va bene così perfetto
perché almeno una tv di allora vediamo
se riusciamo uno esploso visto per
struttura ed io arrivo sul mais arrivo
aspetta non entra o no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no e
no no no no no no che grande beltotto
buono ottimo non difendere risultato
basta spicco 9 grande mamma mia che roba
è ma la mia visuale è sempre avevo
miracolo era un milan
occhio che mi portano in ogni caso era
un the miracle plaid e se solo vai a
farti a centrale ci sono io col 17 di
curvo non entra in trance si entra così
a matrix of the monnalisa is ours guarda
non sa bene non sa chi guardare
bisognerà niente si ritrova lì la magia
del controllo
tira tengono alta per assicurarsi la
vittoria tocco sotto di albert loro è
solo davanti alla vela mette la metro
non oro orario loro di classe di pirlo
guardali tac di esterno destro
gigi gigi gigi comunque mai dire por
fesr al 40 e che veramente non è mai
successo che che poi è facile perché non
è mai facile nonostante il 40 o bella
francesca 17 a 6 chi comincia ma ormai
hanno già dato forfait maledetto male
oro platino 16 a fare uno dei carri a
platino due rinvii daje daje daje buono
poi come come come park per par condicio
di portare su robert voce alle finali
mondiali in realtà sento che devo
arrivare lì avevano appena di grande ma
non è che dura fino a mezzanotte sì
quella è la leader io io pensavo poi a
fare un bel fitball king una volta lo
dobbiamo portare certo quelle una bomba
di saltare li puoi anche attaccare vr la
live possiamo fare il 70 se vuoi il dr
il realtà virtuale ma in che modo è
consiste scusami di cosa nostra è che
giochi con visore ai giochi e ai di
gioco
se stessi giochi pensavo ci fosse un
modo per parlare con la realtà virtuale
dire di no ma ci sono dei sogni la tua
girato al gol
ora va quasi parato grazie icardi
intelligenti belle con la realtà
virtuale
porca vacca di qualche anno ma non la
sapevo sta roba comunque secondo me c'è
un modo tipo tipo come si chiama quella
roba lì dove c'è la room con i
personaggi riceverà come gara
non so come si chiami il gioco
rilasciato mi aiutate a l'ho messa male
vabbè comunque se c'è una roba in chat
uguale ancora facciamo un kit talking
sguardi la live nel 1050 equipe talking
vr bellissimo ciclo di volta una bomba
era capito la battuta si complimenti
complimenti
la qualità comica stasera tensione
proprio lui la mente un tubo per che
ripartono loro bello salto continua il
numero a tommy ma allora non c'è più e
la sbagliano loro nomi spunta qua no
niente eccotelo turbo grazie non solo
ringraziarti questo è quella vacca
l'ospedale che non tiri mattino aveva
diramato grazie al cielo e lapo ciccata
o che cosa
pazzo
ok non so bene cosa fare di questa palla
ora messi lo so non lo sapevi eccola lì
capello non è vero ahia ahia l'anno
sbagliata non ci credo che sarà
difficile da sbagliare è quello era ero
io
non è vero sono storto ha detto mi
apprezzi riccardo prima volta a
quest'ora city ora tira tortora d'ora ha
forato lui store a te dorate amici
torano che cosa sta succedendo tornate
su implorate fortissimo
eccola non sbagliava quanti tori in
porta in questa volta arriva lui salvare
la situazione la situa direttamente da
torino ecco la mappa che sia torino
adesso no no vieni con me perché sei
torinese infatti di cerbo la situa a
tensione se li salta tutti poi va in
cielo
la tocca sotto ottenuta lì dai molto
bene ma se la prendono
ma perché non ha fatto non sull aborto
gli la bravissimo
vai lorenzi sì sì per l'uno a uno sito
quanto sudato asca partita mamma mia
note ragazzi notte chi sta andando
tornate tutti è partito nella mia città
che dorate e dorate tornate lara gut
tutti che tornano durante anche voi
eccolo lui come ti ho saltato sono ciò
che pensavo facesse rimbalzino invece
scesa rasoterra mi frega non è vero la
salva per te che la prova a controllare
per tirare la importa sarebbe stato
bello o no volato a rio lecce sfiga ha
volato stato male volato storto
oggi questa non va in porta arrivo io
vado a prendere il curvo nell'area euro
rubate erano loro e prendiamo gol
no no non tornano rotore non trova ora
credo dorato nessuno che toraco toradora
glielo ruba non così thomas e fanno di
rimbalzo
meno male che con la mancata solo la
problematica molto bene bravissimo cosa
hai fatto fare quello giura pro quello
dove vi faccio io toro tutto il giorno
dava dettori tori così tornati tutti
ragazzi grazie riccardo per la sua prima
donazione butta gentile
grazie mille davvero oggi esagerato
troppo esagerato esageratissimo grazie
mille ma che se per il supporto di avere
partitica ma la cultura del fare se per
te questo è per te bardot l'ho fatto
perché riccardo l'ho sbagliata perché
non segnare invece no lascia un po di
brio alla live lo fanno nell'asta non
segnare giuro ci penso io riccardo
tranquillo poi il mio gol vale doppio si
sa eccolo riccardo a colle arriva ai a
magari impalli palla e mezzo si sarebbe
secondi butta in mezzo di più non fa
niente tre paia smussati tutti il muso
l'accoglimento sono stata in mezzo sono
sta in mezzo
piano piano così è la periodo nord la
chiudono loro cardo dopo leggero mani di
fata lo chiamavano guarderà li mani di
fata gigi ma gli iscritti e sono
arrivato qui ho finito prima getting
over it e dei 5 milioni quindi è stata
una gara emozionante oggi penso ci
arriveremo in questi giorni con quei ggg
very good in atto un po con l'arcobaleno
porta sempre bene ah che bello ha
battuto motore sai che tra poco to fail
platino 3 se vinciamo la prossima giusto
per essere si chiama volere ciatti il
gioco m'han detto i miei sì è vero
grazie jones stoxx configurati riportato
grazie anche a scorpion e se i quali
secondo me si può fare però il setup
guerre devo un sacco a far casino
insomma anche un problema c'è è
difficile se così vogliamo syraka da
problemi stasera i sanniti fi o nessuno
mi importa ma toccano c'è nessuno andava
sulla pallavolo fa aveva piro e sono
conformi agli allora sono scemo però
provare in volta l'ho visto lei capisce
anche lei prova tiro ho tirato rapidi se
il turbo e gol
niente bene la provate nella ritiene la
ii prova cina non fa niente non ci hanno
fregato devi sempre crederci come
rendersi ti sposti in avanti sono in
meno e mezzo si sola messa lui ma
stasera proprio selargius tarata tutta
siamo 41 quanto siamo di questi sono
bravi e stanno facendo volare con me si
no sbagliano un controllo sbagliato ma
se l'avessi truccato sarebbe stato
grande
questi sono incavolati questi anni
questi hanno stata mai cornia questi c è
mostrata nel corpo lo vedo agli non al
turbo ma noi siamo più assatanati vai
tom ripartiamo che li vede l'italia come
fatta è uno stivale
ecco lo sai cosa farci se mi ci si
arriva
provaci bravo tom non era male rimane in
mezzo mia fermi ferma qualche palle ecco
dove sei uscito che tiro non è entrata
per un nulla per uno schifoso mm mia
saltare
ecco la foto a casa qualcosa ma eccolo
ball
vabbè buono dai brutto e mi serve turbo
serie c1 break subito no no no no no no
che scriverà che sia così ma sono
riuscita a tale a nessuno di sotto carlo
mi hai tolto mi hai tolto completamente
dalla palla altamente urbano serviva in
quel frangente ma uno mio sono lievito
questo era gol fatto
vai grazie prego il problema lascia un
turbo minore sera 0 porta raga tesissima
questo è un bravi a questo delle bestie
io noi siamo il club intenso sto ricordi
ma sulla palla
ecco la bella per dal volo ma non è vero
mai nel mondo dell'universo
l'ho presa male aspetta che ci provo ma
mi hai fatto bene a prendere la terra
in realtà che arriverebbero stavo
controllando ema100 pensando da spostato
1 con la tirare sì vado vado vado ma
trovato darmene in mezzo serie a niente
ma era tutto piano taxi del boom
demolito sono questo era gol si spostano
dal fariolo theo lopes all'ingrosso dei
pali che sfiga
aspettavo questo natale non ero
consapevole cava carissimi che se non ho
preso non dovevo prendere l'incrocio che
sfiga queste colpe che sono girato ho
spostato l'altro scusato all'altra
simile come ha fatto a prenderla te lo
giuro è un miracolo miracolo al blady no
viene benissimo male disturba in meno
anche più partita tira nord invece bello
e non avete un film non ci crede volare
l'area ti prego mente proprio di tv
attenzione però la ripresa la ripresa e
se ci sono
no no non ti possono anche adesso ci
conta cinque secondi di un minuto
buttare in mezzo si 40 mesi con di
attenzione di ansia cinque minuti così
partiti incasso sudando sto male ho mai
a chi lo dici dovevo tornare bene
celeste ragionata o di berruto vai vai
vai tom mazzacua ha rischiato troppo ad
andarmene a cantonale ci sono rischi
all'attenzione non bisogna mai capito
che sono fortissimi se vinciamo contro
questi andiamo ai mondiali sono troppo
forti cioè se stiamo facendo miracoli by
toms e io ti prego se io ti prego ti
prego ti prego no non ci credo non ci
voglio avere abbiamo cioè vinto cazzola
cavalcata secondi però contro questi
impossibile giorno sono fortissimi
insomma bene viaggio incredibile alla
grande e ora che faccio lo faccio
ribrezzo questo papa stai scherzando
la prendo al volo perché me la sento ho
studiato a è coniato lo vede è un atleta
e lo fa va in mezzo va in mezzo va in
mezzo a 0 di turbo a 0 di turbo
eccolo dispone non ci posso credere lega
3 a 0 incredibile incredibile hanno
abbandonato anno forfettari gigi gigi
quasi non fare l'ultima perché è andato
tutto troppo bene 41 molto sia perché ti
annaffio con l'arcobaleno è tranquillo
non lo so non fare allora l'ultima
statisticamente la perdiamo perché
abbiamo vinte troppi di fila quindi io
sono contento così però facciamo
l'ultima perché siamo
626 perché la 2 divisione
4 no ma per salire i quarti non ci devi
perdere l'universo tanto che la platino
a 1 fatto divisione da platino
l'adesione a 1 fatto divisione iii
quindi io sono vicino anche la
promozione e io senza possibile da
vincere questa ma ci proviamo lo stesso
perché troppe giardino statisticamente
impossibile
proprio il disagio mi dicono dai è che
il grand champion si avvicina e una
trance rabbia se lei è un attimo regala
un secondo pro vai si vola se vinciamo
che questa cominciò a togliermi la
maglia ve lo dico e anche la cicca
subito o va bene la rete lui uno a zero
si parte così si parte così grazie
all'aria tirreni con gordic a chiedere
la partita di prima grazie riparare lo
grazia fabiano
gentilissimi grazie per il curry valvola
ritengo li vado in pista una difesa out
turbo arrivo non lo controllo sempre
controllata da quando ha iniziato a live
non lo controllata adesso che l'aveva
sbagliata lui che sfiga
sì sì che bella e io sono un po in mezzo
un po no no ma leggo sempre sul primo
quarto gli la ti prego non prendiamo che
così che volta mica fare grande e con
una deviazione minima paolo presa
procedere detto cosa il suo stesso
successo la cosa incredibile non ho
neanche vista non prendere gol
qualsiasi cosa non prendere gol ero solo
scherzando metà va bene va bene
cos'era successo cioè lei cosa mi dici
cosa dovrei fare
guarda sono così non sapere in retro ma
è un casino
dai dai cosa avevo preso peccato era
troppo bello per essere vero
no non ho mai legato azione miss altra
corsa ci sono ci sono
prima va
mamma no e allora vicine ma non potevo
mettere la via io aspettavo lo pensava
la spazza settimana era meglio se
l'avessi fatto io ero messo meglio
lasciare in mezzo ottieni a qualche modo
guardali loren o poi lo re si va dai dai
dai dai cia si sa fare ce la si può fare
due non resta la vista buona bravo auto
mi è piaciuto questo tutti fermi a
guardare credono 7 gradi a loro ci pare
sono vai da prendere turbo una destra ci
siamo se moliti tutti e due no lui ha
demolito me a caso noi è quasi riccardo
non c'è in me non è in mezzo non ce la
fa per ora okaka che tranquilli
tranquilli tranquilli la spazzo via via
dalla mia proprietà
ottimo loro e non sono in mezzo però la
rimetto io indietro nessuno questi
ripartono mica sono i partiti uguale si
tenta buono grande grande grande massa
che vi è fatto un po questa è la rimette
in mezzo di non al borgo po demonio che
sfiga d'oro sono ovunque anno il
teletrasporto va bene avevo 0 totale
male di ictus
quest'ultima è difficile lo sapevamo
prima di iniziarla però mi piace che si
gioca daylight tiene in mezzo a coloro
wood good ma quello il turbo da allora
questi hanno turbo al cento per cento
sempre con è possibile dove lo trovano
tutto questo turno impossibile hai
appena usato come fai a berlino vabbè ho
dato una piccola ma niente occhio via
bravo all'avvitamento londra poi non
poteva metterla in mezzo arrivo ci prova
da lì ma già minchia cosa hanno pre
questi sono allucinanti ma da dove se
prendevo quella era un gol pazzesco
buono questi sono veramente grand
champion o per esempio no però miglia
sono veramente forti
che cazzo è cosa hanno preso occhio
diciamo che gli ho fatto un favore no
era difficile questo era difficile
allora 152 gol fattibile è fattibile
forze ci crediamo fino alla fine questo
ci crediamo fino alla fine ha fatto una
bell'azione era difficile
vai
allora possono ancora credere ci posso
ancora credere
siamo entrambi ci crediamo
per haga per noi però a si vola almeno
personalmente per me lo si fa si va a
sinistra il nostro supereroe
minchia che è successo occhio o no
maledetti stavo permettervela silone
palla che rimane la e va bene va bene e
non ho turbo e questo asso tirate questi
sono cavoli grande errore
ahia ahia non sono in mezzo
ok ci sono questa volta
ecco la sponda mi hanno anche lanciato
no porca vacca mi sto impegnando ente
dai ci abbiamo provato ma c'è stata
proprio una bella partita perché
comunque ce la siamo giocati ma questi
sono veramente forti perché minchia
toccano tool tutto giusto cavolo che
sfiga peccato da non è finita possiamo
provare a crederci fino alla fine
46 secondi paolo palma due gol
proviamoci aria non c'è più turbo quindi
fatto una voi ha regalato la palla verso
la nostra porta a the tonic
dai dai va bene ma perché il amaranta
etica chi ci viene a parate pigasse
genius non è stata di ma sapevamo che
l'ultima era difficile
daje regà sono contento perché abbiamo
fatto delle belle partite grazie tom
bella lorenza come sempre costruttivo
che ha provato
grazie mille ragazzi nei live grazie
mille poi ci siamo ci sentiamo i giorni
scorsi vi ringrazio ciao ciao ciao
ragazzi io concludo qua sono proprio
contentissimo grazie mille
sono proprio contento di tutto spero che
vi sia piaciuto vado che veramente tarlo
fine di far delle robe
grazie per oggi davvero un bacino e noi
ci vediamo a cosa sarebbero un prossimo
video sono proprio stanco
la live diegetico verit rimarrà
leggendaria davvero leggendaria grazie
di cuore per oggi un bacino
ciao ragazzi dalla